...
[Introduction musicale.]
[...]
-Je suis un policier.
Personne ne m'aime.
Et personne, pourtant,
ne veut jamais se dévouer.
Moi j'ai eu le coeur
à contrecoeur.
Mes mains en sueur
essuient..
..mes pleurs.
Et je sèche mes armes..
..en tamponnant.
Faut pas frotter.
Sans quoi ça retire..
..la chaleur.
La noirceur...
La noirceur..
..de l'arme.
Je suis un policier.
Personne ne m'aime.
Et j'ai des copains
dans le monde entier,
..un par quartier,
..un par palier.
Mais l'amitié entres officiers,
..ça ne remplace pas les femmes.
Faut pas frotter.
Faut tamponner.
Sans quoi..
..ça retire la chaleur,
..la noirceur,
..la noirceur de l'arme.
Je suis un policier.
Personne ne m'aime.
Petit gars, tu peux passer, j'ai
les deux doigts sur ma casquette.
Et dans mon pantalon,
..j'ai mon canon,
..pour que ça tourne rond.
Faut que ça tourne rond..
..la terre.
En tamponnant,
..faut pas frotter.
Sans quoi ça retire la chaleur.
La noirceur...
La noirceur de l'arme.
Hou !
...
Hou ! Hou !
[Applaudissements.]